hello and welcome to another night of
chess on psychology
i am dorotheani we have gmpg
um sitting on the new carpet that i got
today
so hopefully it will join us at some
point his ears are moving
but here is that we have a kind of a
cloudy sometimes rainy weather yesterday
was kind of showery but
it's better today um hopefully we do get
the chance
to uh experience some sun
in this summer because man i do not like
the sad weather
all right we have a bunch of cool
tournaments coming up national
and international so make sure to check
the club challenge calendar
and the club event for those two
basically i think from starting um
early slash mid-july we have tournaments
also at the end of october
so um one thing that i definitely want
us to talk about during those events is
the tournaments
but for today i am still taking a dive
into older chess uh
old as 1954. uh last week's we talked
about stains a little
so that was like 1800s this week we're a
little more into the
uh closer so
ah thank you thank you uh njfan
all right let's make a rock and
roll for it and we are looking at swiss
love versus splat winning
so let's go uh i thought this game was
pretty cool especially because
um the way it ended and kind of the
endgame of it
because another thing was that i don't
i i've tried sicilian it's not uh
doesn't exactly
work as well for me as
i was hoping so i don't play it as often
but
i have played this uh closed like trying
to do grand prix
variation from white a lot i still do it
when i play
more like friendly games or shorter time
control
so yeah i think it's kind of cool to
always know how to play it
and one thing that i realized as well
after
in this grand prix cool sicilian those
type of stuff
it's usually a good idea to have the
bishop beyonce
and also to have some sort of like this
pawn structure with the knight on e7
that always seems to um bug me when i
was playing as white
and so here is a little tip for those of
you who might be playing this
alright so i kind of want to ask what do
you think about we need did rice now
there are a bunch of ideas you can get
the knight out you can push the pawn and
get the knight out
you can push this one and get the bishop
out it's very early in the opening but
what do you think he did
so i'll give you a little bit more
detail on this
position like just the history of how
players like it so
smith love kind of really like to play
this uh
knight g2 idea the short castle it's
kind of a
fluid semi-closed idea and
people on like both sides would be
starting to push some puns and maneuver
their pawns and pieces into kind of like
cool strategic form forms and
yeah so i think that's a good idea to
keep that in mind
and it's this game is a lot about space
because historically black is space over
here
white gets space over here so that's one
more thing to keep in mind
and kind of one last comment about
the players um but to wienick
really did not consider this a good move
he he didn't think that this is a good
choice of an opening for white and he
was kind of a
master of strategy and
i believe he actually had a book like
that too so
now um okay so i'm saying some comments
obviously moves such as e6 and d6 are
perfectly fine i'll show you about
something about d6 for example
a knight here then you have you can look
at e5
and yeah black's already kind of out of
opening
difficulties and i'm quoting batwinnick
and yeah white's king um white's bishop
kings bishop it's kind of very nicely
blocked so is our
bishop and this d-pawn trying to move
is a potential but it's not really a
problem if you ever buy a 4 i always
have a 5 so that's another thing
and this d5 is not a real weakness
because even if you try to block it with
two minor pieces
i can always try and defend it with
three
and yeah
now if you try to do like this 95 ideas
i can always
bring it out and and
yep this was actually uh
a very strong suggestion that botswini
cat i'll show you a little bit more and
one of the games
uh yeah so that's very
i want to say logical but that's not the
right word that's very
humane maybe no that's also not the
right word that's
very is there butt winning yeah it's
like it makes some good strategy a mix
of
um like just planning a mix of logic
yeah yeah okay i like that one it's a
very bad thing i'm gonna use his name as
a verb
yeah and then like this is another
weakness and
now i see uh rekha the suggestion that
you gave
now it comes in handy yep
all right so this is not that right this
is not the actual game though that was
just something that i wanted to show
about
if these this d6 was played and then we
could do this e5
uh now there is e6 that i wanted to
briefly touch on as well before we move
on to the move that but we played in the
game
now if e6 bishop gets up knight gets up
knight comes back
trying to do c3s now what do you think
white should do
uh what do you think black should do we
know what white wants to do
this is actually something that um
this is a game that was played and this
knight e2 move was played by smith
himself
versus uh danker in the ussr
uh versus usa match in 1946
yeah and then there was this like
d6 that was played i believe
and there is a chance to take two and
then this would happen
but that's not a good choice because you
end up losing your
district so that's not exactly the way
to go
so let's look at the d6 suggestion now
if c3 knight comes back if you d4 it
take take take take take finally e5 it
and i believe this is playable
but white seems to have the upper hand
already
this is the weak bomb and white doesn't
exactly have that weak pawn for us to
attack
this bishop is not completely useless
it's depending upon
is preventing d vibes and
yeah i think this could be an
interesting
way to work on for white
we try to get too creative with f5s now
i can always try for c4s
and then this knight's gonna get active
and yeah this is um
this is such a good game for white
all right so but that's not the game
that i wanted to talk about this is way
early in the opening for us to get super
sidetracked
so back to move five yay
so we'll uh but when it did not play
either of these moves
mainly i'm assuming because of prior
knowledge
so what do you think
what winnie did now
not knight f6 nope i'll just say it
because this is
it feels a little weird the first time
you see this b6
and yes i i know how it looks it just
looks like
oh my god that's when you're quite
google no he did not
now how do you want to develop
i'll talk uh briefly about this bishop
e3 idea as well but i just kind of want
to give you guys a minute to
just how do you want to develop because
one thing that i noticed
especially when i play with lower rated
players
is that they um like
when there's like a gap of knowledge and
opening
it seems to be very painful to recover
from that
like because if you don't know where you
put your pieces doesn't matter
how good a player you are if your pieces
can't
work if your pieces can't breathe if
your pieces can't be active
it's not going to matter
so yeah that's one thing to keep in mind
all right no not necessarily a6 so um
the move that uh what munich did was d6
so that kind of questions
b6 because you would think you you know
now it's time to go bishop b7 right
but if bishop b sub another is going to
be bishop e3 and this ideas for d4
are getting a little too strong so
94 is possible then take take and then
this is a problem
and no no it's very white has a
comfortable advantage
so let's go back and that's why d6 was
played but before we get too deep into
that
i wanted to briefly touch on two moves
knight h3 and bishop e3
so if knight h3 okay we can get this
bishop out because there is no threat on
d4
yet now castle okay d6
this is actually doable
and i believe this was also
a game um played with queen d7 actually
and uh john timmon played as black
in that championship in 1969
and yeah i think this was a kind of
interesting choice as well
anywho i feel like as long as your pawns
have those choices to move around
uh i still for the okay it's okay for
black
anywho h6 and this is
this makes me a little uncomfortable i'm
not gonna lie but
uh surprisingly this is um
this game isn't a draw anywho
these knights are pretty strong the king
is still okay where it is
so it doesn't matter how strange the
position looks
as long as your pieces have activity and
your king is not super naked
you can make it all right now i wanted
to also talk about bishop e3 really
quickly
so what i usually do in the openings is
i just kind of
throw a bunch of lines up to you and i
tell you these are these possibilities
that white candy these are
responsibilities that black could do i
think this might be the best way for
black to do it
we kind of agree upon a general idea of
what white wants to do what black
is trying to do and then we get more
into the middle game
so i think i kind of like that um
strategy that i do if you have any
suggestions please do not hesitate to
let me know
i am a huge fan of uh
feedback
right now his majesty is having his
light dinner slash snack we napped for a
little bit
before we started we let me know for
like a
half an hour before but we started
streaming so
it feels kind of refreshing all right
bishop gets up let's say we still
continue with the same idea
and uh this is something that smith love
was quite a big fan of he uh
felt that i'm gonna quote better
designed to perry black's blockading
maneuver with this like knight d4
ideas because if your knight is not on
the way when knight d4 happens
eventually you can move this guy away
and play c3
and yeah this was a game that was played
between smith's love and kotov
1946 alrighty
uh yeah so uh in this position
i think it's a good choice to just get
the pieces out get the pieces out
and i believe this are multiple games of
dismissal
smashed together for better
understanding of what's mislove wanted
to do in this game
and as you can see white does have
better
uh rhythm going on in the king side
and i'm not i'm not necessarily
uncomfortable with black's position but
i'm not
exactly dying to get here either and
white eventually went on to win this
game in switzerland
this was actually a different game 1947
not
46 huh all right so uh
that's what i wanted to show you of one
of the possibilities that this opening
could
lead to okay one last before we get to
the main line
f4 let's get the bishop out knight f3
now this is more familiar to
territory for me now this was actually
swisstop kotov in moscow 1947
too this means i've played a lot with
koto
and that's something that happened in
the game
and uh although black seems fine
uh with like slash uh center slash
queensland that's not exactly
uh fair to say because
it's a um
i think white made a little white played
it
too too
safe yeah why play it a little too safe
i feel like here
there was no need to close up the center
just yet
saying wait there was no need to run
just yet you can wait you can
wait for black to spend this move and
then you can go
same same suggestion with bishop d2 same
suggestion of drug b1
black kind of white guy just played it
too chill
and got in trouble and eventually
uh it was a very complex battle but
kotov
actually won it
all right so uh now we've looked into
some of the different possible middle
games that we could get into for this
game so
finally let's get to the actual game
92 d6 castle
and finally let's get the bishop out now
question from the audience just to test
your
consciousness levels f4 or bishop e3
which one do you think should go
should happen first
or do you think is there even a need for
bishop e3 what do you think
any suggestions for you
after d6 can white play e5 uh
i think racco it's a little too early
but that's not the ultimate idea
if wha if white could get these f4s then
f4s and e5s
are the ideas
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and tell
you that in this game
smithsoft did play f4 if he played
bishop e3 now we could consider
the knight d4s and now take
take and you can just try to um
balance the position like this because
white's knight is kind of off off
balance right now this f4s are not as
strong because i have so much defense on
my e5
even if you push it to f even if you
want to reproduce f4 i
might be able to do a five huge might
but that's something that we could keep
in mind
and if not bishop e3 like bishop g5 that
doesn't
really scare us i can always just play
h6 and just then do
our thing so f4 was played
and now question for the audience
black uh spent a few move developing
this bishop
so we are not ready to castle
legally so what do you think black
should do here should we try to
stop this pawn should we try to get this
knight out and castle
should try to stop it with e6 what do
you think we should do
i'll give you guys maybe 30 40 seconds
she's putting out sure
okay i see some new suggestions
with the potential
but i think um so
the idea of trying to push the epon is
very
valid but right now white really really
does want to play a fight
not messing around so we should go for
f5 it's time
if you play something like e6 now he's
gonna do f5 if you play something like
e5 um still f5 it doesn't really hold
that
that is actually a very good observation
yeah but when it
doesn't really seem to care about these
holes but right now this f5 is a serious
threat and we should
face it go for f5
okay well i see people not really um
complaining to f5 so let's just go ahead
um white kind of
went a little um too too
uh happy here and he just went boom
g4 it's very high risk gambit
and yeah this is
um this is not exactly
the way that uh it's recommended for
whites to play
it's not really a clear reason why black
can't
take it and obviously but when you took
it
with it probably a 10-q in his brain and
then white wins for f5
and you're not going to take this one
now i mean i guess it's
possible but then you open up the bishop
so we don't want to do that so
now let's get the queen out we are
considering long castle possibilities
if knight f4 trying to go for e6
now we can take this careful taking over
here
might not be the best choice first
because
now this is another hole for us to
um keep an eye on and there it kind of
makes it unnecessarily complicated
so um
bishop city is not needed let's just
take it over here
and now i have i'm gonna pose a question
should white take it over here or is it
time to get this knight into the game
oh anthony thank you thank you for the
insight
you have a course on swish nichols
unchester
cool
and um yes that is kind of true
that's what i believe black is going for
and i'm not entirely sure why
white gave that up um i'm assuming i'm
assuming you wanted to push
f5 and get some e65 square activities
but was it worth it probably not
yeah i think white probably
overestimated his position
so
okay
i like this idea to get the knight
involved yeah
oh when was this game played i believe
this was in 1954.
uh knights getting involved is fine but
now why a black can just play like
knight d4 if you play c3s now i can't
come attack this little guy
oh actually big guy if you try to go
over there everything is defended so i
can just
um get rid of your bishop oh hello brian
and um kind of just try to
close it up like this and
it's kind of like it's preferable game
although the struggle would
still be very complicated as what wenik
said
i quoted that i am not very good with
coming up with big words on spot
which is something that i also realized
working on my application and personal
statement
i have great ideas and i explained those
ideas but like it takes me
two sentences to explain something that
you could do
very classy in like two words so
yeah i need better english
all right anyways um in the game white
ended up just taking over here
and then black
simply what do you think black did is it
time to cast still
is it time to like try to defend this
guy is it time to get this my test
is it time to activate some of these
pieces what do you think there's so many
options
this move the move that patronic did
right now i didn't have that with that
much trouble finding it
but the next move that he did i actually
had some
difficulties finding that
uh honest yeah yeah i don't think i
didn't think they um no
i don't think smith's love was um
inexperienced he was playing already 10
years before this and winning really
cool games
in the same line either the same line
too
i would be very cautious with taking
this pawn because
uh there are this like knight b5 ideas
and you can't exactly do this long
castling because
take take take move it take
take
it's not very safe i'm not exactly
advantageous
okay what d494 bishop d4
can't decide ah hello alireza knight of
six native six i think is interesting
you defend your pawn but you have to
keep in mind this knight's e6
kind of uh takes it's very hard to come
back from that
do you mean but don't project you still
the position is still
playable but your bishop is very
miserable here and your king is very
stuck here so i wouldn't do that
i feel like if we had like two moves to
play and then we could do a knight f6 if
i like cast all
and then i could do knight f6 i would uh
but it's a little too late like i mean
castling right now is not
as desirable there is still this 96
so yeah let's get let's get the bishop
out the king gotta move
and now what to do now this move kind of
is hard
it was hard for me because i thought
since my bishop is safe i can just
castle
and it should be fine even if you do 96
i'll just move this trick
but that's not the case
so i see a lot of other people are
warming up to
a bishop d4 idea and i agree
but now what remember this is a
kind of a it's not a simple move it's
not but it's a little
um
it takes a little more than just oh i
want to get my night out oh i want to
put my king in a safe spot
knight e5 not exactly hello i
am um de harvin
darwin i apologize i'm horrible with um
pronunciation so i hope you can take it
personally
no i'll give you a hint not a move with
the knights
i know right
no no i mean h5 actually looks kind of
tempting
but no the problem with this 5 is again
this 96 coming up
so your move should be either you should
castle
or you should try to do a forceful move
in order to
keep your castling option the problem
with just getting the pieces now this is
still 96 and it stops your
dream of castling
i'll show you the line with castling
first castling is okay
knight e6 you do chill the rp8 then this
knight gets to get activated
in any of these squares on the city i'll
just let's put it on b5
you try to activate your knights um
there could be some cool checks around
here
and then kick this around
take that take that
and this is a serious issue and because
your king's
your king is kind of quite weak this
pawn gets to come up
and say some hellos
so um he takes f5
uh check he moves no not a move with the
knights
don't touch my knight no knight touching
what else you guys
you're kind of running out of pieces to
move honestly
oh no not if um now taking is not
i explained to taking is not exactly
desirable because
again there's gonna be a lot of problem
with this knight so if you look at
different
lines you realize that this line keeps
getting too
happy so it's good if we could you know
illuminate it hello hi buddy what's up
so now that we've decided on eliminating
the night
now what do we do now is it time to
castle or is it time to try
and dance around with some of these
knights
uh this taking on c3 was quite hard for
me
because i didn't understand the
depth of how much this knight was
bothering black's position
in different variety of lines so taking
was
uh yeah oh okay great honest yeah
no taking on f5 it's still it means
doable but it doesn't help it only gives
white
some ideas on how to
um bother us because your clean doesn't
the problem is that your clean it can't
really go anywhere
after taking if your queen could
actually like take over here and then go
to like h5
and have some ideas okay maybe but
that's not the case
uh long castle is okay but then you move
the slides even if i did work did
not have d4 and this position is also
quite unpleasant for
us so we should still hold on before
long castling
your king is okay here it could survive
no knight h6 the problem with knight h6
is knight going to h5
still has some checking threats some
potential pushing threats
you can't exactly take over here
also the obvious district can't exactly
do any of those
what about this light let's think do we
do we
want to exchange these bishops
why would you go back oh okay i seen 98
but maybe
try you guys want to stop this yeah
doable but no that's not it
the problem with knight d8 uh ultimately
is
knight d5 can go your ninth year doesn't
really have a future that's the problem
if your knight could stay there and have
a future yeah
1985 yeah junior is right
now if you take it perfect my queen will
get into the game
uh in the game uh smith's local smart
didn't take it
queen two now take now sorry knight of
six
uh take take and queen g2 now
do we want to exchange queens
to be fair king g1 was not really
possible because we would just give this
check
and then this is just kind of painful
you could easily just take it over here
you could also just lock castle
there's so much pain yeah don't do that
queen
g2 was quite quite forced now
uh so well he wants to eat my queen so
if i don't want to take it what else
should i do
knight f3 interesting but
i um the my little issue with knight's
f3 is that now your knight is pinned to
your queen
and now he could try to you know play
something like c4
the idea is to play bishop b2 and white
has these two big diagonals
and i don't i just don't
know if that's worth it because if we
exchange the queens
then we are we can decide okay so do
now maybe i want to play c4 to you know
stop your bishop from getting activated
what do we think
how about long castle i think clown
castle is also quite interesting
um but well right now long castle see
again the problem is with the c4 because
this bishop can get very activated
but if i could have the chance to play
c4 myself
then i can actually stop this bishop
from taking over this super cool
diagonal and then yeah if i want to i
can do
long castle after c4 if something like
d4 happens
my knight on f3 is quite strong i don't
need to worry about that
uh if you don't push it as in the game's
misstep just played bishop e3 i'm going
to give you guys maybe 20 seconds to see
if there are any questions
because i can see that there's a lot of
difference like suggestions on whether
or not the queen exchange was good
whether or not
we should be looking into um
you know just developing or pushing
ponds
uh honest i i never really look at it
that way
because it's i don't think see for uh
one of the
other ideas to consider is that yeah
we're trying to find a way to poke those
uh double pawns yeah honestly if i could
play c4 and not trade queens i think
that would be my
ideal way but there was there just
wasn't enough time
okay um now d5 i think it's an
interesting idea to try and
go for it i think um the one thing that
i kind of would want to
do is figure out what to do with this
knight because remember we played c4 so
that he couldn't take over the big
diagonal
now you play bishop b3 you want to take
over this big diagonal so maybe it's a
good idea to stop that first
i think all these ideas are like d5 and
h5 and they're all coming up
but not just yet you want to play bishop
d4 so i want to try and stop that
yeah so now that we've stopped that
uh well technically we're trying to stop
it however smith's love still played
bishop d4
he is a clear pawn down but he's also
having difficult choices to make because
the pieces are
not really in harmony with each other
so the problem is that this type of
exchange
this bishop d4 and suggesting
for uh you know offering this exchange
only kind of
weakens white's um central pawns and
leaves it a little too hopeless for any
kind of active counterplay
so um take
take and finally receive
now to be fair i think instead of bishop
d4 this idea with knight e6
could have been more interesting then
you get your king out knight d4
take take take take and voila
white still has some sort of a counter
play and activity
but this with this bishop d4 all those
went poof bye bye
now take take and question how do we try
and complete our development
okay so i see king d7 and i say king f7
i like that
uh surprisingly botswini made a slight
inaccuracy
and he went king f7 king d7 would have
been
a little bit better because a king is
completely safe
king of seven there is a still you know
is rook looking at it
and if you try as rookie won me i'll
just go rook c
c three i was giving you the persian
number of
sei which is three and okay
and this is something that could have
been
avoided you know fun stuff but you see
when the king is on f7 the king feels a
lot more
exposed all right so he
went for king f7 and
now it's um black still does have a
pretty cool advantage
but but they're still it's kind of
getting a little
um what's this called just a little
pressing for black but black still does
have
good advantage
yeah this is a fun expression the knight
on e6 bites on
granite i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that right
but um basically doesn't really do
anything
and we also have this cool two against
one
all right anywho now white just play
jerky too
now what do you think we should do this
is a pretty cool end game so please try
your best
to um come up with suggestions on how to
continue as black
funnily enough uh white's best
position for the knight would be
potentially just transferred back
yeah but right now it's black to move
i like this idea of rook c3 but i think
the problem is this rock first so let's
do this rook b7
we start preparing this potential
uh white went king g3 and now this rook
moves the other way no more nitrate
vibes either
now in the game white played kingish 4
now what do you think we should play
this 1996 is quite fixed it does it
doesn't really
do much it's not really bothering us as
much as it thinks it is
and
yeah it can't really have any meaningful
action
i like this rook on g8 for inventing
knight g5s
no g3 right now is not needed keep in
mind
this is this knight g5 is what we don't
want so we should prevent that
so
yep you guys got it h6 it is yeah
i think pretty much unanimously h6
good uh after h6 white
i think it would be oh actually it would
be best to try and play rook c2
to you know stop this rook c8 because
that's the one
open super open file and then we'll do
like knight d5
and then bring this rook back and
eventually go to c68 anyways
but white made a mistake and i just
played drugstore too now
well maybe not mistaken accuracy yeah
and
now uh black simply played
rook v8 still activating my rook
rook c2 boom so now um
what's winning sorry smithson played a4
now what do you think what we should do
what do you think boswellic should do
yeah this king over here is kind of
weird too not really doing much
we should trade the roof good choice now
we get to bring this
this cool guy where what two questions
did you do this
why do you think this guy deserves to go
so
yep d4 you guys d5 you guys got it yeah
now you can consider other jumps with
the knight too and also you're
preventing knight
uh this c7 square from getting into it
nice
knight d5 white played rook f2 now we
also have some room for the king to
breathe and attacking this little guy
he went king g3 um i think knight e3 is
possible
too but h5 makes more sense because with
h5
you are also freeing your rep and there
are no more knight g packs because of
your king being here
nice
so now um rekha
yours your suggested line is also
correct
now but winnie finally managed to
improve the position
of all of his pieces and the black king
is also
his most stable coast and
we have so so so much pressure on so
many different bonds and
why is pawns are just sad at this point
um
so
white tried to still fight with king h4
now what do we do do we care about
trying to
uh defend this pawn or is it more of a
[Applause]
maybe we can trap it in something
so
so
i like 93 now if you take it hallelujah
that would be a cool checkmate right
93 is the best choice and in the game
uh smith played d5 and
black here simply
took over here he took over there and
this move was so so so hilarious for me
he's just point a6
he's like you know what your king is
just here chilling
i'm not gonna even bother dealing with
that and you can you're not you can't
move your knights because i'll check my
two you can't exactly move
on or your i mean your your rook is kind
of the only thing you can do so i'm just
gonna play a6 and see what you do
i think this is such a fun funny move
and yeah right and yeah
so next you want to start pushing the
spawn um
[Music]
yeah now white simply played rook b2
and now knight jump we want to go from
the other side
if you try to take kids and i'll still
wants to perform mates
now give me check i'll come back i was
thinking maybe the king could run but
then you'd still have g32
rook f2 can come back i guess you could
also bring the king but the problem is
this rookie 2
and this is not this is not checkmate i
don't think you should be able to
uh yeah you shouldn't give this guy up
this is this just makes it unnecessarily
complicated don't do that don't give
your opponent
unnecessarily chances just play the safe
routes that you know you're gonna have
advantage for
now black would be five why took two
can't
resign because if you take
g3 if you take knight e3 and this is
checkmate in
two three moves if you don't take if you
play like rook f2 i can just push that
pawn
and push that pawn and eventually
start eating your material
one after another or if you want it to
be too
cute then play something like d4
no d4 i guess now b4 is possible
you move the rook b3 and same
suggestions
still your king is way too off of its
place
uh not exactly ricket shade was not
exactly checkmate the g4 pawn was
um okay sure if took then we played
g3 knight goes up to protects the king g
for
the g4 square now i have checkmate ideas
if you
try to be um cute and like prolong it
then i'm just going to check my two like
that yeah
i don't think there was a checkmate
before
a6 yeah see like right now
the king can't take the pawn so we need
to have that pawn defended that's why we
kind of wanted this 93
anyways all right i hope you enjoyed
this game
if there are no questions we are going
to have our segment of switch to twitch
so we are going to switch to twitch in
about 10 minutes
please be ready and send us your games
on
leachat's format either from a game that
you played unleashes or a
great game that you have uploaded to
leeches
and we would love to go over that so
start digging and i'll see everybody in
about 10 minutes on twitch
have a great